So there was one thing I teach and I
want to remind you of it.
It's really simple things.
Getting things not going to make her
happy.
That's good news in a tough economy,
it's a good reminder.
You know it doesn't matter what you get,
doesn't matter whether it be money or
opportunity.
All those things might excite you for
the moment.
You know,
even a relationship as magnificent it
may be,
might be exciting for a while,
but if you don't keep growing,
that relationship isn't going to stay
excited.
So the secret to real happiness is
progress.
Progress equals happiness.
And if we can make progress on a regular
basis,
we feel alive.
And that's why at the beginning of the
year we get this thing like,
okay,
I can have this fresh start.
I could really do what my soul desires.
I can expand.
I could grow,
I could improve.
I could change or maybe better than
change.
I could progress.
See,
think about that progress as an a
liveliness to it,
doesn't it?
You don't have to work at changing.
People say all the time,
now I'm working on changing.
Don't worry about it.
You don't have to work on changing.
Change is automatic.
Your body's going to change whether you
wanted it or not.
As the years go by and I'm going to how
hard you work,
there's going to be some changes going
on there.
The economy's going to change no matter
what you want it to do.
The weather's going to change.
Relationships are going to change.
Everything in life is always changing.
We don't have to work on change.
Change is automatic,
but progress is not.
So if you want to make real progress,
then you really got to look at your life
in a different way.
You gotta say,
I gotta take control of this process and
not just hope it's gonna work out like
people do who make a resolution cause
really isn't that what they're really
doing at the beginning of the year.
They're saying,
well here's my resolutions for the year
and they really basically tell you their
wishes.
It's their wishlist.
It's what they hope.
It all comes together and then they call
it a resolution,
but they don't know what a resolution
is.
When you resolve something,
to have a resolution is to resolve it.
When you resolve,
this is how it's going to be.
That's when you cut off any possibility
except the thing you've committed to.
It's like the old adage,
if you want to take the island,
you burn the boats.
Cause when you burn those boats,
there's no going back.
You're going to find a way to make
things work.
And most people,
they're stating what they hope will come
together.
And if it doesn't happen,
then they're disappointed,
but they're not too disappointed cause
they're not too vested.
What does it take to successfully create
a lasting change in your life?
To not only have a new years resolution
you fall through on,
but really have a lasting change?
Well,
the first step for lasting change is
very much like making a new year's
resolution.
Fundamentally,
it's the same.
The first step is you've got to have a
vision,
a vision for what it is you really truly
want,
not what you think you want and what you
should have.
I mean,
what are most people's new years
resolutions?
I'm gonna stop eating sugar and I'm
going to stop smoking.
I'm gonna lose 10 pounds.
Problem with that is it's not very
inspiring for most people.
You know?
It's not telling you what you're going
to get.
It's only what you're not going to do,
and it's Kinda hard to have you move
forward with that.
A vision is about what you're here to
create.
A vision that really works is one that
excites you.
If you say,
well,
my,
no,
my resolution,
my goal,
my outcome for this month,
this week,
this year is to lose x number of pounds.
That's okay,
but it's not very compelling.
It has to be a compelling vision.
It's got to have something,
has the power to pull you,
not something you have to push yourself
to do.
Well,
the two different kinds of motivation,
push requires willpower and willpower
never lasts.
What will last is pull.
Having something so exciting,
so attractive,
so somebody who desires so much that you
have a hard time going to sleep at night
and you get so up early in the morning
to a rocket and take it to the next
level.
That's what you're looking to create and
that was it.
Easy to get.
But one of the reasons we do seminars
and events and he's saying,
you know,
why do that?
Why isn't my not just read a book or
something?
It's because when you get an environment
where you're with people that are being
put in a peak state,
like when you're going to a sporting
event,
if you watch a sporting event at home,
it might have a certain level of
excitement,
but when you're in a stadium with 50,000
people,
suddenly it has a whole different level
of intensity.
When we feel that in the bottom line of
our follow through comes down to our
emotional intensity in a different state
of mind,
you're going to come up with a much
better in a more exciting vision than if
you're sitting on the couch going,
okay,
what am I new revolutions for this year?
And you're doing it the morning after
the new year started and your little
inebriated and the football games on in
the background,
probably not going to have the power of
focus.
They're probably not gonna have the
power or the energy to create something
that's going to pull you for this year
and you've got to do that.
So it's gotta be a vision that's
compelling,
something that no,
it's going to be a gift to make sure
that it happens.
And also along with that compelling
vision,
you got to have strong enough reasons
that you're going to follow through when
the going gets tough.
That's one of the biggest things missing
for most people.
They said,
this is what I want to do.
It's not very exciting.
It's not very compelling,
but most importantly,
they don't have strong enough reasons to
push themselves through what's going to
be necessary to get that dream,
to get that goal when the inevitable
challenges come up,
when you're starving,
hungry and you're trying to go on a
diet,
right when you got no time and you're
stressed out and you haven't worked out
still,
and that's what you're supposed to do.
When the economy gets tight and what you
thought you're going to do doesn't work.
And so you give up on the goal instead
of finding another way to get there.
You don't let the fear take you over.
If you've got strong enough reasons,
those reasons can be positive or those
reasons can also be negative.
They can be,
if I don't do this,
this,
it's going to cost me.
And if I do to this,
this is what I'm going to gain in my
life.
Reasons come first,
answers come second.
If you get a compelling vision and
you've got strong enough reasons that
will push you through the tough times,
you're gonna do things other people
don't do it.
It's been a collapsing.
Even if you get off target,
you won't go,
Oh,
I blew it.
You'll get right back on target.
Make the change,
make things happen.
And I know you've done this in many
areas of your life.
Just think about it again.
I'm not teaching you something really
new here today.
I just want to remind you of what your
soul knows.
You gotta change,
you gotta improve and you gotta go
through a simple process fundamentally
to make that progress.
First step vision,
that's compelling.
Second step,
make sure that they're strong enough
reason to follow through.
Third step,
you got review it and feel it every day.
I mean anything.
Have you ever had this happen in your
life?
Has there been anything in your life
that you've ever wanted so badly?
You were so desirous of it,
you have such a hunger for it that you
couldn't stop thinking about.
It could been a career move.
Could have been when you're a kid,
a car.
It could have been a relationship,
it could have been anything,
but you were obsessed.
You wanted to make this happen.
You want to attract this to your life.
You want to,
you just wanted something and you didn't
even know how to get it,
but it was so compelling to,
you kept thinking about it every day,
envisioning it,
imagining it,
feeling it,
and then stuff happened and suddenly you
started to attract people or situations
to your life and it just came together
like you didn't even have a total plan.
It was just that it was so a part of
your focus with so much intensity and
emotion so often that it's sensitize you
to notice anything that could get you
there.
There's a part of your brain called the
reticular activating system for short,
we call it the Ras.
That part of your brain determines what
you notice in the world and it's really
important because when you set a goal,
when you get really clear on a vision,
they're strong enough reasons and you
review it enough and it becomes a part
of you,
that part of your brain says,
anything that relates to this,
I need to notice.
It's like,
did you ever buy a certain kind of car
or maybe a certain outfit and suddenly
you see that car everywhere,
those outfits everywhere.
You know the cars were always around,
but why do you see it now?
Cause your Ras knows this is important.
This is part of my world now.
Similarly,
when you really get clear and it's
compelling and you're reviewing it every
day,
got strong reasons,
you're reviewing it every day and you're
feeling it.
The brain becomes incredibly acute at
noticing anything to get you to move
forward.
And so that's the power of this.
So you know,
what do people do with a new year's
resolution?
They come up with something they kind of
want,
if not a compelling vision,
they don't really have strong enough
reasons and they never review it again
until the notice that they broker what
they said they really want to have make
happen because they didn't really
resolve you resolve.
You've got the vision,
it's compelling,
you review it daily and you feel it,
you envision it and you experience it as
simple as it sounds.
Now ultimately,
what does this really about?
Ultimately,
if you're going to have lasting change
in anything,
you're really talking about just raising
your standards.
I mean,
I always tell people,
if you want to know how to change your
life and give it to him,
three words,
boring as it sounds,
raise your standards and what does that
mean?
Corny as it sounds,
raise your standards.
So thank you for the breakthrough
thought,
Tony.
I'm glad I wasted my time watching the
little email with you.
But think about it.
Lasting change is different than a goal.
You don't always get your goals,
but you always get your standards.
Maybe it will help you is to think about
it this way.
I try to explain standards to people
with a different set of words.
Think of it as everybody in life gets
their musts.
They don't get the shits,
but think about it.
Most people have a list of shoulds,
don't they?
Don't have a list of the shuts things
you should do.
You should follow through on I,
I should lose some weight.
I should work out more.
I should make more calls.
I should respond more rapidly to my
email,
whatever.
You know,
I should get into the office earlier.
I should be more confident.
Whatever your should list is.
People love to have their should list
make me mad,
but it's kind of like New Year's
resolutions.
If it does,
it's really exciting,
but if it doesn't,
which is most of the time,
yeah,
it's a little disappointing,
but you kind of know it's not going to
happen,
but when you decide something is a must
for you,
an absolute must.
When you cut up any possible,
you just say,
I'm going to find the way I'm going to
make the way.
Human beings,
when they resolve things and they have
to make a real resolution inside
themselves,
which is they raised the standard and
they make it a must.
They find a way to think about it in
your own life,
how could you add some area of your life
where you raise your standard and your
life has never been the same?
Maybe at one time your life,
you smoked cigarettes or he did
something and you did it for years and
you kept trying to change it,
trying to change it and kept telling
yourself I should and the one day
something happened,
something just clicked you over.
Something took you over.
That kind of tipping point and inside
yourself you said no more.
There was a very,
very different experience,
wasn't it?
Something inside of you shifted and what
was a should became a must and you've
never gone back.
Is there an area like that in your life
you can think of again?
Do you ever smoke cigarettes?
Did you ever eat a certain way?
Drink a certain form of alcohol and then
finally saying no more and you just
don't go back and notice this.
It doesn't really take any willpower
anymore because somewhere when we make
this click,
we make something a must.
We attach ourselves to it.
It becomes part of our identity.
One thing I've learned in the last,
Gosh,
33 years at working with people from now
over a hundred countries,
4 million people,
is human beings absolutely follow
through on who they believe they are.
And you said said to me,
well,
I'm really going to work hard to stop
smoking,
but you know,
I've been a smoker my whole life and
I'm,
you know,
I am a smoker.
I know your days are numbered.
You're gonna be back smoking cigarettes
again because we all act consistent with
who we believe we are.
I tell people the strongest force in the
whole human personality is this need to
stay consistent with how we define
ourselves.
If you define yourself as somebody who
is really conservative,
you're not going to be crazy and act
nuts unless you're really drunk or
something.
And then you can say if the alcohol,
when it's really just you finally
getting permission to be yourself.
The alcohol is your excuse.
If you're really crazy person,
you act crazy,
outrageous,
playful.
You don't act conservative because
that's not who you are.
Very often people say,
well,
I can't do that.
I'm not that kind of person,
and I always say to people,
really,
when did you define yourself?
I mean really?
How many years ago did you come up with
what you could and couldn't do in your
life?
How many years ago?
Most people,
if they really look at how they're
living their life today,
it's based on a set of standards,
a set of beliefs that they made choices
about 10 2030 or more years ago.
I mean very often we made decisions in
our youth or very young about what to
believe about what we were capable of,
about who we are as a person,
and that becomes the glass ceiling,
if you will,
that controls us.
There's a corny metaphor,
but it's true.
I remember one time I was with my family
at the circus and there was a person
there and they had this big giant
elephant.
And you look at this elephant and they
take this little rope,
put it around the elephant's neck,
and they drive the stake into the
ground.
And I mean,
you look at this and you know that
elephant could written down the entire
tent with almost no effort.
And yet the elephant doesn't struggle,
doesn't try.
Why?
Because the elephant is conditioned and
they take that elephant condition.
The elephant,
when it's a baby elephant,
that's how they train them.
When if a little baby elephant and it
doesn't have the power yet,
they put a big rope around it and they
drive this huge stake in the ground and
the elephant fights and fights and
fights,
and one day finally that elephant
decides,
I'm not capable of pulling this out.
And once that becomes the definition of
an identity of anyone,
an elephant in this case,
they don't even try anymore.
It's just who I am.
That's how it is.
That's just the way it is in my life.
I'd like to ask you to take a look at
any place you've got a limitation.
Ask Yourself,
when did I decide to accept that
limitation?
And you may not even see it as a
limitation.
You might see it as just that's who I
am.
But so often our lives,
we've adapted to be a certain way so
that we don't fail or so that people
will like us or respect us,
but it's not necessarily who we are.
Joy comes when you're spontaneous.
It's really hard to be truly happy when
you're not being yourself.
And most of us have no clue who we are.
And so a big part of my work,
if you've ever been to an event you
know,
is to get people to do things
spontaneously without thinking because
that's when the real you shows up.
That's when the energy comes alive.
And when you do that,
when you start to connect your true
nature,
suddenly there's energy available for
you to set a higher standard for what
you want in your life.
That's what this is really all about.
And when to talk about standards.
When I talk about [inaudible] versus
musts,
think about your own life.
I know there have been areas in your
life where some point in time you just
shifted and you raised the standard in
your life changed because whatever
people have their identity attached to,
they live.
We live who we believe we are.
That's just how it works.
It just kind of like I give an example.
Look at your physical body.
Your physical body today is an absolute
reflection of only one thing,
not your goals,
not your desires,
but your standards,
the identity you have for yourself.
If your standard is you're an athlete,
then there's a certain amount of
strength,
a muscle tone and energy that's
available in your body on a regular
basis because that's who you are and so
you do whatever's necessary to maintain
that identity.
Again,
the strongest force in the human
personality is this need to stay
consistent with how we define ourselves.
Because if you don't know who you are,
you would know how to act.
Once you lock in on that identity,
your brain finds a way to keep you
there.
If you say,
uh,
you know,
man,
I'm overweight,
I've always been overweight,
I'm big boned and that's the story
you've got.
Then you're going to always find a way
to get back there.
That's your settling point.
That's your identity.
That's where things lock in.
If you see somebody who's in really
great shape,
you ask him,
do you work out?
You know the answer?
Yes.
How often?
And they'll tell you three times,
four times,
five times a week,
whatever.
In a seminar.
Last people who here works out at least
five days a week and I'm stand up and
you look around that room and you know
that they work out five times a week.
As you can see their body,
you don't just get a result without some
kind of action,
without some form of ritual,
ritual meaning actions you do
consistently.
Now,
do you think he knows people that are
out there working out five days a week?
Do they have more time than you do or I
have or anybody else?
Of course,
no.
Is that a white less busy?
Of course not.
It's just a must for them.
They must work out that way and they've
made that turn their life change.
So I'm not saying you have to work out
five days a week.
I'm just saying whatever you really
want,
wants,
don't get met consistently,
standards,
do whatever you identify.
This is who I am.
And so it's not so much about changing
your identity as there's expanding it,
you know,
deciding that you know,
instead of your goals to lose 10 pounds,
which is not compelling.
What if your vision was to get back to
my fighting weight?
You know this,
this year,
this month,
this next 90 days I'm going to transform
my body.
I'm going to take on a new challenge.
I'm going to find some technique or
strategy.
There's a million of them that can
reframe myself where I want to feel
younger,
stronger,
more vibrant than ever before.
Here's my reasons because I want the
energy to really make my life work
because it's tough out there and I want
to be stronger than I've ever been
before.
I want to go in front of the mirror and
if I'm making it not,
you know,
want to laugh,
I want to look there and take a good
look and go,
yeah,
I'm proud of whenever I see there,
whatever it takes,
someone's going to make you laugh,
smile,
something that's going to tease
yourself,
but someone's going to move you to
another level.
If you identify yourself in a new way
and you own that every day,
and that becomes the standard how you
live,
you'll find the way to make that
standard.
Real money's the same way.
Think about it doesn't matter what's
happening,
quote unquote,
in the marketplace.
People that make money find a way to
make money no matter what,
don't they?
I mean,
most people's standard is to pay their
bills.
So that's what most people find a way to
do.
Even when economic times get tough.
Most people,
if that's their absolute standard,
they find a way.
Some people's standard is pay their
bills most of the time and some,
most of the time they do.
Some people's standard is not just to
pay their bills but to take care of
their family and maybe even some of
their friends and they find a way.
In fact,
human may,
some people may be in a family where
they don't have enough money to barely
have money to pay their bills.
They work their guts out and then
somebody,
their mother or their father or somebody
else,
their sister gets ill and there's not
enough money to take care of it.
Nobody else has money and family.
They don't either,
but they find a way to get that money to
take care of their mother or father
don't pay and pay their bills.
They never could do it before.
Why the situation made them raise their
own standard and not everybody does
that.
Somebody else in the family might have
money and still not take care of their
mother.
It all comes down to the inner game.
My friends changing your life is a
change in the inner game.
The outside world you can't control,
but you have absolute control over this
one.
If you learn the dynamics of what shapes
you and identity is one of those simple,
clear,
fundamental basics that if you start
start to shift it,
everything else will shift in your life
as well.
Some people are,
by the way,
have to have more than enough money to
do what they want.
When they want,
where they want,
with whomever they want,
contribute the way they want.
That's their must.
They find a way.
I know that sounds overly simplistic,
but it's true.
Now,
somebody wants said,
you can take all the money in the world,
out of the hands of everybody.
Out of all the wealthy people in the
world who are really successful,
given other people,
it wouldn't take too long.
Those people have it back in their
hands.
It's not because they're manipulative,
it's cause they have a standard.
Some are manipulative,
don't get me wrong,
but they've got a standard of what
they're gonna find a way to make happen.
I'm just simply saying to you,
take those three magic words and live
them.
Raise your standard if you really want
to do it.
And I'll tell you the most important
secret.
Have you ever done this?
Have you ever told yourself,
you're raising your standard?
Okay,
I'm going to go make this happen.
I'm going to go make this much money.
I'm going to transform my kids.
I'm going to create the ultimate
relationship in my life.
I'm going to transform my body,
whatever it is,
and then you don't have strong enough
reasons and you don't lose use it.
You don't follow through.
It's because you didn't back up your
standards with what makes those
standards real and that's rituals.
Rituals are the power is whenever we do
our Robbins results coaching,
you know he's in Robbins equals results.
Wait,
we get results with people with the same
way.
If you listen to my ultimate edge
program or back in the old days,
personal power,
or if you went to one of my seminars,
you know what I do is I take these huge
challenges you've got and we break them
down into little bite size steps,
little things you do each day that after
you do them,
you get so much momentum that it's easy
to succeed.
You're not overwhelmed.
You have these victory day after day
after day on little things.
If you'd went to ultimate edge,
I'm sure you learned about the hour of
power or the 15 minutes to be able to be
fulfilled or 30 minutes to thrive where
you literally just condition your body
and emotion with a couple little rituals
so it doesn't matter what's going on in
your world.
You feel that strength and it's not
fake.
It's not some pump up.
It's coming from inside you and it
works.
Rituals define us.
See all the results in your life are
coming from your rituals.
They start with a standard and then have
rituals that fallen up like for example,
if you are where you want to be
physically,
you have very different rituals than if
you're not where you want to be
physically.
If you're overweight,
you and I both know you got a different
ritual than if you're physically fit
completely different.
You get up in the morning,
what's the first thing you do?
If you're fit,
your shoes are there.
You roll over the metal that you feel
you put on the shoes,
you lace and you start walking or
whatever that ritual is.
If you're overweight,
you roll over and you have a very
different ritual.
You might roll over several times that
turn the alarm clock off.
You go in and get your Mocha Smoko,
whatever you know,
special coffee you stop by at starbucks
or the case may be you have your nice
sugar muffin.
You know it's supposed to be really nice
for you.
Whatever you do,
it's a different ritual.
If you have a great passionate
relationship,
you're very different rituals and how
you come home.
Then if you have a lousy relationship,
become come home in.
The first thing you do is you're
tweeting somebody or you're emailing or
flipping on the news or you don't even
come home and what are the rituals?
Whenever I study people that are
successful,
well,
I look for is what's the standard they
hold themselves to and then what are all
those little rituals that up because
think about it,
success and failure are not giant
events.
They don't just show up.
You don't just suddenly become
successful or suddenly have this
cataclysmic event that makes you fail.
It may look that way,
but failure comes some.
All the little things.
It's failure to make the call.
It's failure to check the books.
It's failure to say,
I'm sorry.
It's feel your to push yourself to do
things physically that you don't want to
do it.
All those little failures day after day
come together until one day some
cataclysmic event happens.
You blame that that event happened
because you missed all the little stuff.
Do you agree with me and success by the
way,
is not some overnight event.
It's all these little things.
Success is having a vision.
Success is making it compelling.
Success is really seeing it,
feeling it everyday was strong enough
reasons.
Success is feeling the sense that I'm
here to grow and I'm here to give
something to the world more than just
myself.
Success is caring about other people.
Success is calling and saying,
I love you in the middle of the day for
no damn reason or sending a note that
will change your relationship.
Have a ritual of something funny,
playful,
or a surprise.
You knew how many relationships are dead
today because they have no surprise
rituals anymore.
You need to have some rituals,
some cool things you do that nobody else
does that gives you a better life than
anybody else has.
All the little stuff.
That's where success comes from in
business,
it comes to delivering more than anybody
could imagine.
All those little things that have people
go,
wow,
that's who I want to do business with.
It's true in any area of your life.
So if you look at somebody who's really
successful and you think,
wow,
I mean they're,
they're so amazing,
they're such a genius.
You got to dig underneath and you've
gotta remember something.
People are rewarded in public for what
they've practiced for years in private,
myself and my business,
people say,
how do you get up and speak and he'll
know notes and you go for three days and
nights in the room is like everybody's
wired and it's incredible.
It's like a rock concert.
How do you do that?
How do you have that confidence of hall
and you know,
it's not confidence,
it's experience now,
but I did so much behind the scenes and
I still do to make things right.
I mean how many people would know that
since the time I was 17 years old before
I walk on stage,
still do to this day wouldn't need to do
it,
but I still do it.
I never walk out there without being in
an absolute peak state of mind.
You know,
there are days my back is hurting,
my throat was hurting or I may have had
a challenger,
my father passed away and I've still got
to deliver for these people cause my
standard is give my all,
every time.
Every band has to be better.
Talk to anybody who's been to our events
for five,
10 years.
Some of our trainers,
I don't know,
he does it.
He's always finds a way to make it
better.
That's not an ego thing.
That's a standard in me.
I have to find the way.
And my ritual though is I prepare,
I think I got the new information.
I figured out how to put something
across better.
What do people need?
I spend time with our customers.
I see what's going on and before I get
on stage,
each time I have to a ritual to put
myself in a state of mind.
And I did it starting from like 17 years
old.
I started doing it and say,
I now command my subconscious mind and I
say this out loud several times,
this little phrase set of phrases as an
incantation to kind of condition my mind
and body.
And I'd say I now command my
subconscious mind to direct me in
helping as many people as possible today
by giving me the strength and the
emotion and the humor and the brevity,
whatever it takes to show this person
and help this person change their life.
Now.
And I started out with a person when I
work with people one on one and I will
do that for 45 minutes driving in my
Volkswagen to go serve and coach
somebody for the first time.
Now I don't say that person.
I say these people and I can go out in a
room of 10,000 people and deliver for 50
hours,
and I do it every time I come back on
stage.
It's a ritual,
a ritual to go into peak state.
Peak states don't just show up,
they don't interrupt you.
Great ideas don't interrupt.
You got to pursue them.
I talked to Michael Jordan,
I'll never forget at the peak of his
career and got to watch his final games,
saw him backstage and spent some time
with them and it was pretty exciting
time was greatest basketball player and
I think that ever lived and has ever
lived.
And I asked them,
I said,
you know what sets you apart Michael?
You know,
what is it and is it God given talent,
ability,
skill,
what does it?
And he said,
Tony,
you know,
he said,
I can shoot you straight.
And you know,
it's not,
you know,
me trying to act humble.
He goes,
I have a lot of tell a lot of God given
talent,
a lot of skill.
I've worked really hard.
But he said,
really it's my standards.
He said every day I demand more from
myself than anybody else could humanly
expect.
I'm not competing with somebody else.
I'm competing with Lon capable of
magic formula because most of us lower
our standards.
Why?
Because please spend time with my
friends.
Who Do you become?
One of the biggest reasons I started
going to seminars when I was like 17 as
I have nobody around me as a great role
model,
I could read about somebody,
but being around people,
being in the environment was very
different.
Finding where to go to work with someone
who lived at standard life is very
different and get around people with low
standards and you compete with it.
You don't need to compete with it.
It's like,
okay.
I mean number Jerry Springer know if
he's still in the air,
but I've never used to get people on the
show and I thought where would he find
these people and why would people watch?
I'll you why they watch they watch these
people.
Don't my wife's know pretty darn good.
Compare that person,
learn of him.
You don't have to change your life.
All you have to do is find somebody with
a lower standard and you'll feel good
about yourself.
But if you feel that good feeling,
it's an illusion.
The only thing that's gonna make you
happy,
my friend in this year,
any other,
is to step up.
It's to raise the standard.
It's to discover what you're capable of
and feel that incredible power of
pushing through whatever's holding you
back and get to the other side of more
of your true self.
That's what this game is all about.
And look at the best of the world in
anything.
Tiger Woods,
what's,
what's his vision to win golf
tournaments?
No,
to be the best that ever lived.
That's his goal.
That's his vision.
But here's what's interesting.
He backs it up with rituals.
If you just have a vision and you don't
have the rituals,
stop lying to yourself.
His rituals are,
he started doing things nobody did
before he went,
started lifting weights,
golfers lifting weights,
no way.
He went out and he changed his swing
when he was the best in the world
because you realized in order to be the
best that ever lived,
he's gonna have to change his swing.
If you don't think about golf,
you don't change your swing when you're
the best.
And he went and retrained himself
because he has different rituals than
other golfers.
Now,
many people are modeling his rituals to
get better.
It's amazing.
You know,
you look at somebody like Michael
Phelps,
the 2008 swimmer won seven,
you know,
only two people I think in history,
if I remember correctly,
that have gotten seven gold medals in
one session.
And here's a guy,
he's got number six centers belt and
he's exhausted and he's going in for
that final swim.
I'm sure you remember.
And how does the guy win by 100th of a
second.
Do you think that was some massive skill
that got them over the top or was it a
standard that says,
this is who I am,
I am the champion and no one has taken
us from me.
And somehow in those final
sub-millisecond hundredth of a second,
he pushed himself just beyond his
competitor.
But you know about Michael Phelps.
What allowed him to be able to push
beyond that moment is his rituals.
Go study the guy.
Most people who swim have these
unbelievable workouts.
He does two and three of the workout
sessions a day.
All the other swimmers in the beginning
thought he was insane.
You can overtrain you can't do that if
not physically possible,
but he had a standard and the rituals
tobacco.
So here's my final message to you cause
I've gotten carried away.
I thought I was going to send you like a
five minute message,
but you can see there's no script here.
Just me going a little crazy with you.
But I want to really see you get what
you want this year.
Don't let this year be like last and if
last year was great,
still don't let it be that way.
Raise the standard.
If your life is perfect and
extraordinary,
you darn well know you're not going to
be happy unless you keep making it
better.
That's what makes us feel alive.
It's not what we get to make us happy.
It's who we become and what we're able
to give because we become more.
That sense of contribution is what
creates the deepest meaning.
So here's my assignment for if you want
one,
if you want to go from conversation to
some action here,
simple thing to do.
What's an area of life right now that
you really want improve?
What's an area that's important to
improve?
Your body's great.
How much crew careers?
Great.
How about your relationships?
Intimate one especially or your kids or
your relationship with your Creator,
spiritual side of your life,
or is it your finances?
Figure an area that really matters.
Decide on that area.
Number one,
write down what your life is like in
that area right now specifically as
possible.
So you might say,
well,
I'm 13.5 pounds overweight,
whatever the weight is,
whatever the situation is,
or my body fat's like this,
or I'm pr,
I wake up exhausted in the morning.
And you're right.
The truth of where you are right now.
So you're real clear or I'm not in a
relationship.
I say I want a relationship.
But I,
I'm not in one.
I don't seem to find them.
All the good ones seem to be gone is my
belief,
you know?
And I really do want one,
but I don't have it.
Whatever your definition,
I'm in a relationship and God,
I wish I wasn't in a relationship.
I'm planning my escape wherever you are,
or I have a lot wonderful relationship.
We love each other,
but there just isn't enough passion.
Just write the truth of where you are,
the or you want to change,
but write how it is.
And then the second step is this where
you gotta be really honest with
yourself.
What are the rituals that have put me
there?
Because whatever results you're getting,
even if you don't like the results,
there's some rituals that are keeping
you in that place.
There's some rituals of what you eat or
don't eat,
how you move or don't move,
how you sleep or don't sleep.
There are some rituals in the lack of
variety or spice or energy or focus in
an area.
There's something you're doing and it's
usually not one thing.
It's a bunch of little things.
They kind of do consistently.
Whenever you think about getting in a
relationship,
whenever you think about working out,
whenever you think about money and get
yourself in a state of overwhelmed,
you start thinking about all the things
you can't control.
Just write down all the rituals you have
and then here's the third step.
What do you want?
What's your vision?
And be really specific.
I want to be my fighting weight.
I want to be the strongest I've ever
felt I want to be.
I'm going to turn my whatever it is,
be specific.
And then last step number four,
what are the rituals that will get you
there?
What would you need to do differently
each morning if you're going to be that
kind of energy,
that kind of strength?
How would you have to,
how often would you work out?
What days would you work out?
What time a ritual,
something you do consistently,
usually at a specific time,
so it becomes automatic.
Let me tell you something.
We'll bauer doesn't last,
but rituals can last a lifetime.
I bet you have some rituals in your life
right now you've been doing for years,
even though some of them don't serve
you.
I'm just saying wake yourself up.
Make if you want a new year and a new
life,
you don't need to start in January 1st
start today.
Start with this little video and just
begin to see what happens and see how
easy it is to just do a few little
rituals.
Don't do them all.
Just do two or three new things and you
don't happens.
You'll get momentum because once you
discipline yourself in one area of your
life,
you feel yourself doing it in other
areas as well.
I always say something that my original
teacher taught me.
Always remind people there's always two
pains in life.
There's the pain of discipline or is the
pain of regret.
Discipline weighs ounces is my friend
Jim Roan taught me.
Regret weighs tons.
You don't have regret.
So right now,
what do you want to change?
What's it really like?
What are the rituals that got you there?
They will take a little homework if
you're not sure half the people around
you.
They'll tell you what your rituals are.
What do I really want in depth,
one of the rituals that will get me
there,
and then get yourself to start a few of
those actions and lock them in place so
that can help you in any way.
We're here as a company to support you.
Come and have an event with us.
Come to unleash the power within or
mastering university,
or get a coach.
You can get a free coaching session.
If you call our company and Click on
something on this,
we'll probably have something on it or
get a product or don't do anything with
us,
but do something with somebody starting
with you.
If you make the changes in yourself,
you're going to be proud this year and
no amount of money or accolades,
letter people can mirror the feeling of
being proud of knowing you've taken back
control of your life or you've taken a
great life to another level.
Because once you do that,
you have something you can give other
people.
Would it be your kids and your friends
and your family?
And ultimately that's why it's about.
So thanks for listening.
I don't know how long I went to here,
but I hope this has been helpful for
you.
I just thought it's a new year and I
want people to be able to truly create a
new life,
and until I see you again,
hopefully soon or get the chance to meet
you live strong and live with passion,
then of course,
God bless to you.
Happy New Year.
Okay.